another week another Grand Theft Auto  mod and if you're a crisis fan this  one's just for you I'm Tony and this is  your super-powered GameSpot news update  the latest GTA 5 mod comes to you from  Julio and IB and it brings the crisis  Nanosuit into the game as you'd expect  wearing the suit greatly boost your  speed strength and jump height it also  totally redesigns the UI with a weapon  selection wheel and HUD that resemble  Crytek's classic PC shooter you can  download the mod yourself from the GTA X  scripting blog and to stay up to date on  all the latest GTA experiments don't  forget to subscribe  the Nanosuit is one of many many GTA  mods out there some current projects  include bringing the full maps from gta4  and red dead redemption into the game  and speaking of big maps why not check  out some of our gameplay from the  upcoming platformer ukulele  [Music]